Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my God.
I know.
Surprise sponsor, everyone.
Not on schedule.
Surprise!
Today, we're having triple streams.
Let's go!
Look, I did say we might not have double streams today, but I didn't say we don't have triple!
Fuck!
But Doki, on your schedule, it says one stream.
Well, after this, I have a collab I have to do right after this.
I'm not streaming the collab.
I'm just gonna show up.
And then after that, I play Silent Hill.
Oh my God.
Oh, baby!
It's a triple!
So, yeah.
Anyway, surprise!
We have a sponsor today!
For those who don't know about the Ascendant, earlier today...
Not today.
Sorry, guys.
I'm a little bit messed up at the moment.
I'm getting ready to play Silent Hill, so I didn't take my...
Guys, it's a joke.
That was a joke.
But, like, I'm trying to get into the character of not taking meds.
Just to make sure my dead wife is still alive.
Anyway, for legal reasons, that's a joke.
Take your meds.
Anyway, we are playing the Ascendant!
It's out in beta right now, which means you can actually wishlist this game and try out the beta now for free!
So, if you want to support the stream and the sponsors, please click on the link in the description or pinned in the YouTube chat.
And wishlist the game.
It really helps a lot.
Anyway, for those who don't know the Ascendant, we actually played this before.
I think like a month or two ago.
I've actually lost all concept of time.
For me, a day passes when I have zero work to do.
And a day has yet to pass.
I don't know what that feels like in a long time.
So, I have lost all concept of time.
I don't even know when some streams... I don't know if you guys know this, but Sage Jam Slam was like...
The Sage Jam Slam was maybe like... Was it a month ago?
It was even less than that.
It was like three to four weeks ago or something.
But yes, the first time we played this game, we were not sponsored.
And then we were joking around and like, you know, we were cyberbullying the devs to sponsor us.
And it worked!
The message is not a good message.
Don't cyberbully people, guys.
It doesn't work all the time, guys.
It's not a very good message, but it worked.
So, we did it, guys.
We got sponsored, chat.
From playing the game for free to being paid... to being paid to sign...
Okay, okay, the...
Okay, so, this really fucked up.
But, they were like, oh yeah, we can get you that dev so you can like harass and...
If you really want... It was so funny watching you harass our dev like that.
If you really want to, you can play with him again and then you can...
You can harass him again.
So, I was like, okay, I'll do an hour.
I just wanted an hour of just like, hanging out with you guys.
I was just like, I was just like, what the fuck?
So, it worked, guys.
We offered this dev as a sacrifice.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not a very good message.
The moral of the story is, don't cyberbully.
I got paid to, so like, legally, it's okay for me.
I'm getting paid to be toxic.
It's all just fun and jokes, guys.
It's all just...
Anyway, guys.
Like I said, feel free to check out the link in the description and pin on the YouTube chat.
You might even be able to get into my lobbies today, too, if you downloaded it already.
For those who don't know...
Alright, get ready, guys.
It might sound like I'm reading off of something.
Because you're like, wow, Doki, I've never seen you so articulated before.
But look, this is part of the sponsored, okay?
But...
Ascendant is a groundbreaking squad-based tactical FPS set in a vibrant retro-futuristic biopunk world.
So it's like in the 80s.
You guys have already seen it before, but basically it's like in the 80s and stuff.
It revolutionizes the genre with its unique adaptation mechanics.
Offering an ever-changing battlefield where strategy and adaptability are key.
And you gotta engage in intense 3v3v3v3...
Oh god, that's a lot of 3s.
PvP battles navigate ever-evolving landscapes and secure vital resources in a world where every match is unpredictable and different.
There was no way for me to say this in any natural way that I usually talk.
So it's clear.
But yeah, you can play it right now!
There's a chance to get into my lobbies.
My lobby is literally in NA.
Yeah, I know, it sounds very natural, guys.
Everyone, please clap.
Everyone, please clap and download the game now.
Anyway, let's try this again.
I sort of forgot how to play this game.
My brain is like...
After a long time, I'm like, how do I play this game again?
Oh, I got achievements!
Oh my god, that scared the shit out of me.
I was like, who the fuck is talking to me?
Wait, am I alone?
Is there nobody?
Oh no, there's a real person!
Hey, real guy!
Is he real?
Oh my god, wait, these are all the stuff.
These are all the stuff I got from the other bait.
Is this a real guy?
I don't think he's real.
I can't tell.
Are there any real people in my lobby?
Wait, I remember there's like the 1v1 stuff here.
Like, I know the lobby is like super interactive.
Hey, I'd like to see what you're selling.
Do I have money?
Wait, I know my devs are watching.
Devs, if you're here right now, can you like give me...
All I'm saying...
Devs, my account...
What is my account's name?
Devs, if you're watching...
Wouldn't it be so funny...
If like, I try to buy something...
And then my account money...
And then I don't...
Oh hey, Jackie!
Daytona!
And then like, you know, I go into this...
And then all of this is like...
I don't know...
100,000 coins?
That'd be so...
It'd be so fun...
Chat, wouldn't you guys think that'd be the funniest thing you've ever seen?
And it's gonna make you guys wanna download and wishlist the game...
Even more, chat!
No!
Guys, come on!
It would be so funny!
Doki, they're already giving you actual money...
And you want virtual?
Yes!
Guys, you always... You gotta take your shot, guys!
Like, you always have to take your shot!
Oh!
Okay, I remember...
Oh yeah, by the way...
The lobby has like, a lot of...
Different things...
Cause I remember there was like, hide and seek...
There was like, 1v1s...
Oh, there's a spider now?
What the fuck does the spider do?
Um, there's the hide and seek over here...
We've done that...
And then the tryhards going under...
The tryhards who played the game like, 200 million times...
One, of course...
Um...
And then there's...
Who asked me if I was in the right version?
Don't make me paranoid!
I'm like...
I'm pretty sure I'm on the right version of the game...
And then there's...
What's this?
I know there's like...
There's like, a lot of places I didn't explore...
All I did was went straight into the game...
Wait, I wanna customize...
I know there's like, customization too...
By the way...
Devs, I don't know if you know my username...
But it's definitely not Tokibert...
Maybe you got a little confused...
And that's why I don't have like...
$100,000 coins in my...
In my inventory...
Maybe that's why I gave it to like...
Tokibert, but like, not Tokibert...
Because you're thinking, that can't be Tokibert...
There's no...
There's no way...
There's no way that's Tokibert...
That's all I'm saying...
Oh wait, what does he say?
Sport modules...
Oh, it's like...
It's more attack...
I don't need those...
Much off of my teammates...
Jesus, spoiled his...
I deserve things!
I deserve it!
Oh, and then you have like...
Abilities and perks...
So you can customize your...
Abilities and stuff...
I remember, everybody had like...
All the abilities in the fucking world...
And then I got shit on...
Because I didn't know how to play the game back then...
But I do now!
I do now, guys!
So now, I'm gonna shit on these fools...
Buy a custom weapon?
I don't need a custom weapon...
I have all I need...
Alright, let's go over here...
Uh...
Do I need anything else?
Okay, I have extra space...
I have a shield...
I have all of this...
There's no way I'll get shit on...
I'm a gamer...
I don't even know if this is my current sensitivity...
We'll see...
Uh...
Alright, guys...
Don't worry...
Because when you're new, you didn't know what to do...
But now you do!
So all you have to do...
You see this computer over there?
You see that computer?
You customize...
Don't forget to do this...
When I first played...
I forgot to do that...
And don't forget to talk to...
Talk to the ladies...
To buy stuff...
Because then...
Now you know!
I'm here to make sure you don't make the same mistakes like me...
Make sure to talk...
I know talking to people is very difficult...
But like...
I know, guys...
You gotta learn how to talk to all these women and men...
You see the exclamation points?
You gotta buy these things...
I know it's very hard...
And they're very handsome and pretty...
But you have to learn to talk to women...
To get the things you need...
You guys...
And sometimes men as well...
You gotta learn how to talk to the men as well...
To get the things you need...
Guys...
I know it's very difficult...
But I believe in you guys...
This is how you're gonna learn...
Why can't I just talk to them online?
I'm fine...
And there's like...
This is like...
My reputation is not...
Oh wait...
Do I give my 1?
I shouldn't give him upgrades...
And stuff...
For cosmetics...
That sounds terrible...
I need to upgrade my ability...
I know...
Oh, but then I would look so good, though!
If I upgrade my cosmetics, they'll know I'm fucking styling.
They'll know my reputation.
It's so high, so then they won't cyber-bully me.
They'll be like, oh my god, that girl's pretty fucking cool.
We won't cyber-bully her.
Oh, I think the shotgun was my favorite.
I didn't like the sniper, because the sniper at a low level is not as good.
I think the shotgun, as a beginner, was the best.
But yeah, you can customize, basically customize weapons and characters and everything.
Does anyone remember how to customize the person?
I mean, I'm already perfect right now.
He's perfect, but like...
I mean, look at me.
I'm already...
Does anyone remember how to customize the person?
Like, I don't really want... I mean, he's perfect already, but like, I'm just wondering.
No game audio?
I'll make sure... I'll boost up the game audio a little bit.
I mean, look at him.
He's even wearing a fucking crop top, too.
Peak performance, you'd say?
Yeah, exactly.
I'd say he's even peak performance right now.
Alright, I guess we're ready to play.
We're ready.
We're ready to game, guys.
If you downloaded the game, you might have a chance to play with me right now.
I don't need tutorial.
Famous last words.
I don't need the tutorial.
I can... I remember.
I played... I played... I played games where I had to farm.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, it's teams of two.
Oh, I did the game mode.
Alright, guys.
Remember when I said it's 3v3v3v3?
It's 2v2v2v2 now.
Guys, I should have read.
I chose the game mode where it's 2v2v2v2.
Guys, it's okay.
We're learning to read as well.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta beat up the snails.
We gotta beat these guys up.
And then we gotta get... Oh, hey, nice.
I got armor already.
Look at that.
Okay, I'm... See, I told you guys I can remember how to play video games.
Oh my god, this guy's played.
Wait, this guy's played longer than me.
Wait, how does... Wait, he knows where all the snails are.
Yeah, we gotta farm snails.
Oh, there you are.
There you are.
That's fucking right.
Give me your money.
Alright, so I remember we gotta farm snails.
And then... And then after that, you use them to buy stuff.
So, I mean... Don't worry.
He knows how to play the video games.
So, like, I believe it.
Oh, hey, that's a blue snail.
That's blue.
He should have more stuff, right?
Okay, money.
Alright.
Guys, we're here to make sure that the snails... What are snails good for anyway?
Oh, shit.
Like, we're here to destroy the snail population.
Don't be like, no, my snail... You guys never gave a shit about these snails.
Don't fool me.
I know you guys didn't care.
For the French, then we definitely need to get rid of... Oh, my God.
Oh, why is it two?
I'm leading them to my teammate.
Oh, hey, nice.
There's more snails.
Nice.
Yeah, see, they're invasive species.
I'm just trying to... Did you guys know that we have...
This is a really... Guys, this is not a fun fact, but fun fact.
We have eliminated 75% of the wildlife population.
And I'm gonna make sure it's 76%.
All right, where is my teammate going?
Where are you going?
I hope I'm not open mic.
Oh, wait, no, I shouldn't be.
There's no way.
Let's try... Whoa.
Whoa.
Oh, I forgot I have limited ammo.
I should use my pistol.
I knew I forgot something.
I should have been using my pistol.
Wait, he's leaving me.
Okay,
wait, he's leaving me.
Why are you leaving me?
We gotta... We gotta buy stuff.
We gotta do the thing.
Where the fuck is he going?
Hello?
Did I just leave him?
It's like, I thought we had to be a team player, sir.
Oh my god, they're all just... Wait, wait, wait.
Are you still farming?
What is there to farm?
They're just snails.
Solo queue moment.
Where are you going, sir?
Wait, I can slide.
Are you still farming?
Guys, this is not MOBA.
He really, really hates the snails.
Doki, you don't understand.
You don't understand.
Bro, we're not playing a MOBA right now.
Get back in here.
Is this like... Is this their house?
Oh, it is.
Where's our house?
Oh, where's our house?
I like... Oh, no.
Where's our house?
Where did we live?
He got me so... Oh, it's over... Where is... Oh my god, our house is all the way over there.
This guy got me so confused that we never went back to our home.
Alright, I'm heading to my house.
He's not even going home.
Why don't you want to go home, sir?
This is our house.
And then... locate... Alright.
Nice, we did it.
Okay, there we go.
We did it.
I have zero... Like, my teammate is so far away.
Like, I don't know what his plans are.
Oh, my plans are this, though.
That's my plan.
Oh, I got the bush!
Yeah, that's right.
That's my plan.
That's always been my plan.
What's going to happen to me?
I'm going to die?
That would be silly.
That would be so silly.
Oh, wait.
Can I take their gun?
Is this better?
Oh, no.
It's just the same.
Oh, the shop's closed.
Oh, my god.
I'm so... Don't worry.
He's farming.
Maybe he's aiming for late game.
Look, late game is very important.
I'm going to head to the shop.
I don't know what he's doing, but I'm heading to... He's still farming, guys.
Don't worry!
Are you serious?!
I'm
farming this!
Oh, my god.
Give me.
Where do I deposit?
Where do I...
There we go.
Oh, give me.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
All right.
We did it.
I don't know what I did, but we did it.
Let's try.
Let's buy this right now.
I don't know.
Is this better?
I'm fucking panicking right now.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'm trying to figure shit out right now.
I don't know what we did, but we did it.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I'm heading... No!
Voxel, you farm so much!
What was the point of farming?!
Oh, what the fuck?
No.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Give me the fucking loot.
That's fucking right.
You there!
Oh, I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry.
I literally just killed two.
I'm so fucking sorry.
Oh, shit.
Wait, where?
Oh, my god.
That's fucking right.
Give me your... Goddamn shit.
Bitch.
You there.
Fucking...
You fucking there.
I can't believe he was like, are you there?
Come deposit!
Fucking, I'm going to deposit you.
Get over here.
I'm fucking letting my anger out on these fucking snails.
Oh, my god.
I'm fucking... I'm heading over!
You don't get it.
The snails killed his family.
He has to have his revenge.
James, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm coming over.
I'm fucking... I'm heading over.
You stupid fucking... Oh, I'm heading over with your goddamn money.
What do you... What do you want me to do?
Oh, he's going to die?!
Bro!
Oh, my god.
How?
Um, where are you?!
Ah, shit!
Ah, you're dead!
Okay, that's fine.
I'm fine.
That's not my fault!
That's on him for dying!
It's not my fault he's bad!
It's literally not my fault when people are bad.
Oh, my god!
No!
I didn't even see this fucking... Okay, I still have four more lives.
I still... It's fine.
It's fine.
I have four more lives.
I can't... My money!
My... No!
How could I deposit?
I couldn't.
I couldn't deposit.
I... I wanted to.
Okay, don't worry.
I got a fucking steward.
It's not my fault they're bad.
Good shot.
Bro, he doesn't believe in me!
He fucking insta-dies!
Look, all I'm saying is that if they're dead, then, like, we win automatically.
Wait, where?
I don't even see them.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, I need... I need your heals.
I need your shit.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
I bet the money... I don't even know where I died, guys.
I don't even know where I...
I don't even know I'm... Oh, shit.
Okay, there we go.
Get down!
Get out of my fucking lobby!
That's fucking right!
I don't need heals!
Get out of my lobby!
Guys, we should do the objective.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry!
I'll actually do some!
Oh, my god.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'll figure this... No, I forgot to punch him!
I'm fucking heading over.
Oh, god.
I... It'll be fine.
That's the worst that could happen.
Oh, he's fucking... We all... We have to work together, bro.
We... Bro, other guy!
We had... Bro, why did... Please!
We had to work together against him!
It was objective.
We have to get the blue thing.
Oh, I swear to god.
I swear to god.
Bro, he's so low.
Like, I got him so fucking low, man.
I swear... Oh, you... Oh!
I cracked him and everything!
I... I don't know.
I cracked him.
Oh!
I even cracked him, bro!
Guys, I don't think my teammate and I are... Guys, my teammate and I, we don't work together very well.
I think he's mad at me.
I guess... I guess I'm not a team player, guys.
A team player.
Hey, hey, even if I'm not a team player, I'm getting these frags, though.
Yeah, guys, it's not my fault.
It's not my fault my teammate's bad.
It's okay.
It's alright, guys.
Bro, he was like farming for 200 years!
It's not my fault!
I got impatient!
I was like, stop farming!
We fight!
We fight and steal their farm.
That's how I fight.
I fight by stealing their farm.
It's like, basically, you gotta farm to grab items, to buy items, and then, like, get these objectives.
But, like, I'm a fragger, so...
And then, beating up snails gets you money and also, it gets you... Oh, shit, we don't want that.
It gets you money and HP back.
That's why... I have a purpose to beating up the snails.
It's not because I... It's a hate crime.
Like, they actually give me back my HP.
So, like, it's not because I'm a fucked up individual.
I literally need to beat them up for health.
That's what they all say.
Doki, it can be two things.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Oh, what the fuck?
Bro, this is not fair.
BRO!
YOU HAVE A PERSON THAT ACTUALLY PLAYS WITH YOU!
My teammate fucking collapsed!
I should've just waited.
I should've just waited until...
I should've fucking waited until another team shows up.
Okay.
Don't worry.
It'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
I believe.
We'll just play the weight game.
We'll be little rats.
We can do this.
We'll just be little fucking rats, guys.
Truly.
Look.
Although I wasn't a team player, it's his fault that he didn't play for...
It's his fault that he didn't play around me.
I came from Overwatch.
You gotta play around the one trick.
I am the one trick.
I hear shooting.
Oh, it's over there.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is that?
Oh wait.
I dropped my shield.
SHIT!
He's using a shield that had nothing!
What the fuck is...
Okay, that shit scared me.
I was like, oh hey, shield.
If I click that, is that me?
What fucking...
Why is there a giant gorilla slapping me around?
It smells revenge.
It's okay.
They purposely... I still have two more lives.
It's fine.
That's fine.
It smells fire in the head.
Wait, where are they?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
We gotta kill him.
He came out of his shell.
It's fine.
Look, this is why we gotta kill all the snails.
This is what happens.
This is literally what happens when you don't kill all the snails.
What is he just standing there?
He's not even moving.
Oh my god.
I don't even know where he was.
Where he landed on.
Guys, I'm scared of the giant hitman.
Oh wait, that was him with the...
No, there's no way.
What the fuck?
Is that his gorilla?
Don't worry.
I'm heading over.
I'm gonna run him off.
He thinks he can get away.
I have a car.
Is that his pet gorilla?
Bro, it is!
That's actually...
I'm literally getting shot at by his...
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
He has a fucking pet gorilla!
No!
Oh my god!
Help!
I want a fucking pet gorilla!
Giant ass monkey.
I thought he was chasing him.
I didn't realize.
It was literally...
It was literally his pet.
Holy...
How do I win this?
I'm one man.
That's why I farm.
Oh my god.
If I knew I could have bought a giant fucking gorilla by farming, I would have been back in the snail territory.
Just for that, I'm gonna crush you like a great, great, great ape, Vegeta.
Oh my god!
Bro!
Is it just me and him?
Oh my god.
You know what?
I'm fine.
I don't want to fight him anyway.
I didn't want to fight that guy anyway.
I don't know about you guys.
He had a fucking gorilla on his team.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm just like, yo, I'm fine with that.
I'm...
Bro, sick this creature.
Butcher.
Oh my god, that's all he did.
But your teammate wanted to buy...
Bro, that's all he did.
I told you, that's all he did.
All he did was farm the gorilla.
Okay, that was funny.
Guys, okay, guys.
Guys, if you play...
If you're good at this game, you can buy a fucking gorilla.
Yes, I would like to play this again.
Why?
Because I love this game so much.
And also, I was sponsored.
I was sponsored.
Nice.
Help us improve the performance.
Yeah, that was pretty good.
I got slapped by a gorilla.
There you go.
Nice.
Yeah.
Well, no, actually.
No, because...
I don't think I ever got slapped by a gorilla before.
Yeah.
Yeah, the gunplay is.
Please tell us anything.
I've never been slapped by a giant gorilla in an FPS game before.
Oh, shit!
Winston!
Shit, sorry.
But I've never been slapped by a giant gorilla.
That was not Winston.
Winston.
There we go.
Hey, not last!
Not last!
I got...
You guys know this.
This is that.
See, guys?
Not last.
That couldn't talk.
True.
Wishlist now?
Oh, yeah, guys.
Remember to wishlist the game.
Oh, I saw that.
Maybe lower my sound effects.
Let me...
Where's the options?
Audio.
Sound effects.
I'll lower the sound effects a little bit.
Alright.
Well, now I know.
I'm gonna buy some guns.
I'm gonna buy some guns after that.
Which one's the gun seller?
Map.
Alright, so these are all the things that we can buy.
Oh, hey!
Is that me?
Oh, these are other people's games!
Ctrl -Shift-B.
Alright, let's see.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm gonna buy this.
I think I'll need it.
It's like a shield.
I'm gonna buy a fucking gorilla.
Okay.
After this, we're gonna ask the devs, how the fuck do I get a gorilla on my team?
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
This is for a carrier ability.
I should have read better.
I thought I could use that the entire...
That's fine.
Now I know, guys.
Guys, now every day, I learn to read a little better.
Chat, that's my goal in life.
Alright, what do they have?
Oh, combat perks!
Do I afford it?
Oh, no.
Receive from at least any dodge that I would kill or down you while at least this can only trigger once every 20... Oh, wait!
No, I like that.
What's my reputation?
Oh, my god.
This guy wants so much money from me.
This is still not...
Oh, my god.
Guys, my reputation went up one, but I still can't afford it.
It's okay.
One day, I'll be just as cool.
One day.
One day, I'll be just as cool as all the other people around here.
Alright.
This time.
This time will be better.
This time will go better.
I believe.
I...
This time, my teammate will be better.
And if not, we're grabbing the Devon here and then he's gonna make me the fucking strongest gun ever and then we're gonna win.
And then we'll win.
The moment...
The moment we get that Devon, it's over for the lobby.
Like, it's not even gonna be fair for this lobby.
Alright, who's my... Oh, he's live, guys.
Okay.
I think the shotgun is the best, honestly, for...
Okay, he might have to change his gun's name, though.
It's not a pocket!
I just...
He just has everything in the game!
He has the best guns!
At that point, it's just GG's!
I win by sh... Guys, it's not... Guys, I have the... I have the aim.
I just need the right gun.
Hahaha!
The devs are pocketing me.
Alright, all... Look, I'm not an objective person.
All I...
I'm a fragger.
So, all you do is feed me kill... Feed me the people and then do the objective.
I'm not the... I'm not the Lucio on the cart.
I've been the Lucio on the payload for way too long.
It's my turn to kill.
I'm gonna... Must kill all these snails.
Like, I beat up so many snails.
That should be enough, right?
Alright, get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get your fucking ass over here.
Get your... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
That's fucking right.
Get your ass over here.
Alright.
I think I can deposit.
That's where our... Yeah, that's our house.
I can deposit a little bit.
Oh wait.
Eighty... Oh my god, that's not enough.
Alright, let's see.
Climb up.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, activate.
I remember.
We gotta activate this and then we can see where things are.
Unlocks a tier 2.
Oh!
Okay, I want a tier 2 actually.
So it guarantees that I'll have a blue shield.
Alright, I need five more snails.
God, where's the... Where the fuck is the... Where the fuck... Oh, there they are.
Oh, I see you.
You know what?
I don't really care about... Oh wait, maybe it has...
I need to go over for the money.
I was gonna say...
You have to, like, go up and pick up the money, too.
See, guys?
I'm not that stupid.
I can remember things.
Okay, we gotta...
Oh, hey, another snail.
Get your ass over here.
Get your fucking ass over here.
Oh my god, nice.
Tier 2.
And then more money.
Alright, that's good enough.
We got this.
Watch this, guys.
I'll show you how a gamer fucking works.
Alright, do I need to buy stuff?
No, right?
I don't know...
I don't know if I should.
I should, actually.
I'm gonna go to the shop.
I don't know if I can afford anything.
I can't remember how expensive things are.
Alright, watch this.
You see that gust over there?
Watch this, guys.
Weeeew.
Wait, what's that?
That's purple.
Is that the shop?
Why is it purple?
Oh, okay.
Shop time.
Can I afford anything?
Uh...
Okay.
Um...
Oh...
Wait.
How come you can afford stuff?
Wait, what?
How is...
How...
How did he buy that gun?
I thought he was broke like me.
No!
I need one dollar!
I actually...
No,
no, no, no, please.
No, no.
No!
That's fucking right.
That's right, I'm gonna smack your ass.
Get your ass smacked right now.
Oh my god, I got that one dollar.
Yippee!
Wait, where's the shop?
Wait, where did the shop go?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I went the wrong way.
I was so excited.
I jumped down.
Okay, nice.
I can afford it now.
Let's go.
Okay.
Buying.
This has to be better.
This has to be better, because it's...
It says it's...
Okay, 119.
We should get a medkit.
I feel like I always need a medkit.
Wait, no, I'll grab a shield.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, what is this gun, though?
Alright, don't worry!
Oh my god, this guy knows what he's doing.
Don't worry, I'm heading over!
I'm coming over!
I'll be a hero.
Wait, who is he getting shot at?
It's so bad.
I'm gonna walk in a straight line and you won't be able to shoot shit.
Bro, if that sniper was in my hands, it'd be over.
Come on, where are you?
That's not even right.
Oh, it's you again!
You know what?
Give me that sniper.
Now that it's in my hands, I'll show you how it's done.
That's not even right.
I'm gonna slap that ass again.
Show you how it's really done.
I'm not sorry.
Shouldn't we go over and get the fucking thing?
Why are we going for A?
I would love to farm that one guy.
Over and over again.
I recognize those cheeks.
Wait, where's my teammate doing?
Don't we wanna get to that guy?
Oh my god, I'm climbing.
I like how...
Oh my god, wait, that's really far.
You know what?
No, he can have that.
I saw how far it was and I'm just like, you know what?
You can have that.
My laziness has won today.
I'm good.
I'm okay.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's a bot.
It's not even real.
Is he trying to shoot?
Who is he trying to shoot at?
Oh!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh, please leave me alone.
I need this.
Okay, now I know.
Oh no.
Was I him talking?
I couldn't tell if it was in-game VC or not.
Okay, nice, I killed him.
Where is our...
Where's my guy?
Oh, there he is.
How the fuck did you get...
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, he died.
I was like, who's talking?
Who's trying to interact with me?
This is an interact-free zone.
Oh no, no!
I just shot him already!
Oh my god!
Okay, yeah, no.
He's definitely talking.
He's real.
No, he's a real person, guys.
Just sus.
Wait, how do I heal?
Sus, bro.
Guys, I know my guy's a real person, guys.
Where...
What?
Where's the fight?
Oh, underneath!
Okay.
I didn't have to, but I did.
I was contested.
Oh, I didn't...
Oh my god, I didn't hear him!
Oh my god.
I didn't hear him!
I'm so stupid!
It's just fucking ridiculous.
This kid's gotta be cheating.
This guy's mad.
This guy's mad already.
Bro, why is he so mad?
No, I forgot to deposit!
No, I'm a whitey shield.
I'm a whitey shield.
I did not expect that.
I did not.
Bro.
Fuck kills me, he's cheating.
Oh my god, wait!
Oh my god, I thought he died already.
I was gonna be like...
I knew that.
Yeah, I believe it.
Oh my god, the toxicity.
He has one life.
Please don't die.
You have one life left, please.
I don't wanna be alone again, bro.
I can't.
Wait, there's a snail.
Maybe he has blue shield.
Okay.
Just here for the blue shield.
He didn't have blue shield, guys.
There's...
I'm like a little lost.
Time to carry the...
No, not again.
Not again, please.
There's too much pressure.
I need to get...
What?
The fuck does that mean?
What does that mean?
A dinosaur?
Oh, she...
Become the...
Oh!
Oh my god, I'm gonna be the monkey!
It's over.
I'm him.
How do I get out?
Oh my god.
It's so fucking over.
Now I know how he did it.
Now I'm him.
Bro, what do you want me to do?
Do you want me to go in?
I fucking know.
Bro, bro.
Now I understand.
Protect...
Friend.
Doki got a parkour.
Give me a sec.
Gorilla has a parkour.
Gorilla has to take the stairs.
Gorilla trying to figure out how stairs work.
Whoa!
Gorilla getting shot at!
I don't know from where!
Bro, do I heal from this?
I don't.
I don't know where I'm getting shot at.
Give me intel!
Oh my god, it wasn't wildlife.
It was an actual giant fucking person.
He gave me all the comms and then suddenly no comms as the gorilla.
What does he want from me?
I heal.
Oh, he got it.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Where is he?
Gorilla don't speak people, Doki.
What do you want me to do?
I don't...
Oh my god, gorilla getting shot at.
Gorilla scared.
Gorilla has no idea where shots are coming from.
I'm like the most confused monkey there is.
Like, it's above me.
It's fucking above me.
Okay, he's gonna regret this.
Gorilla jump!
Where is he?
Where?
I'm just trying to figure...
Oh shit, he's heading a nuke over.
Oh my god.
Oh, there he is.
He's a fucking coward.
I see him now.
I'm gonna spit on him.
I'm gonna spit on this guy.
I see you.
I'm gonna fucking head over soon.
That's right, there is a drop off.
There's drop off, that's right.
I fucking figured out the drop off.
That's fucking right.
I figured it out.
I figured out the drop off.
You think I don't know?
You think I don't know the drop off?
You think you can just do that?
You think...
You think you can just do that and things will be okay?
He's like...
I'm gonna spit on you.
I'm gonna fucking...
Fuck, I'm ready.
I'm mad.
I'm fucking ready.
Where are you?
Oh, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Oh my god, I'm too fucking thick.
Oh, get over... I'm too thick right now.
I got... Where did he go?
I wanna kill one person.
I swear to god.
Just...
Oh, you think... Oh, I see you.
You think you can get away from me?
You think that's right?
That's fucking...
Oh my god, that's right.
That's fucking right.
Oh!
Jesus Christ.
Is this not...
There we go.
He thought he could get away.
What's my purpose?
What is my purpose?
Is my purpose just Roman?
I don't know what my purpose is anymore.
What is my purpose?
Human!
I don't know what my purpose is.
He's farming!
I'm following him!
I thought he was gonna do something with me!
That's it, I'm heading over the sea.
I'm heading over...
Monkey business.
That's your purpose.
I thought we were gonna get sea together!
What happened?
Oh, shit!
Ah!
That's right!
Yes!
Oh, I spit on your grave.
That's fucking right.
Where are you?
Oh.
Wait, where's sea?
Oh, there's sea.
Where's my guy?
Oh, he's dead?
Oh, no.
I can't pick that up.
I'm unable tonight.
I don't get anything for that.
Wait.
Did they put it in the truck?
Is it in the truck?
Oh, it's... Oh, my God!
It's a ray!
Are you serious?
Like, I don't... Oh, my God!
What was that point?
There he is.
You can shoot him, shoot him.
Yeah, shoot him.
That's right.
And I'll shoot you, too.
Oh, I spit on you.
What the fuck?
What the hell?
That's right.
I need a heal.
Gorilla heal.
What?
How is he...
Why is he still talking about cheating?
I've been gorillaing all this entire time.
He's still fucking talking about the guy that's cheating?
It's been 20 years.
Let it go.
Like, let it go.
20 years have passed since we fought the guy.
I'm literally a giant gorilla.
You gotta let it go, bro.
This is my gun now.
This is my gun.
Please.
Where's my teammate?
I've been spitting at people for 20 years.
I can't pick it up.
Bro, he's dead.
I can't even pick it up.
I'm a giant gorilla.
That's the worst part.
Bro, the best I can do is spit on people.
I can't pick it up.
He's dead.
I'll just do this.
Get out of here.
I just wanna kill him.
That's it.
That's fine.
I did my job.
Monkey dead.
I killed him though.
Guys, I got so many kills by just guarding that one area for 20 years.
Monkey hours are over.
Oh my god.
For 50 years.
I fucking spit on so many people.
Oh my god.
Are they an enemy?
Oh my god, he's working together.
I guess we'll both work together to kill that one guy together.
Come on.
We can work together to kill him together.
He has to go this way.
That's fucking right, I knew it.
What are you doing?
What is he doing?
Give me a sec.
I'm just reloading.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
My turn.
No!
We'll win this.
I wanted to melee him to death.
No, the melee didn't.
I'll crawl away.
Bro, the pistol has no ammo.
I thought I could win by sheer melee.
I'm just gonna crawl away.
There's no way.
I'm gonna crawl away until I'm there.
Okay, we have two more lives.
I did not in fact win that.
Okay.
I got killed by him.
How many lives does he have left?
I don't know.
I wish I was him.
There's no reds.
There's no way.
There's no reds left.
Okay, we'll see.
How far away is it?
It's not that far.
There's hope.
We can make it.
It's him again.
He thinks he can get away?
He really thinks he can get away.
Guys, he's getting away.
Guys.
What the fuck?
Guys, he's getting away.
Guys, I think he is getting away.
Oh my god.
Wait, he is.
He really is.
Holy shit.
He's fucking with me.
He actually is.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
It's my turn.
Bro, I'm fucking taking your red gun.
What the fuck?
Oh my turn.
My turn.
Wow.
This is fine.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
One minute?
Holy shit, he just goes up and grabs it.
What the fuck?
He just walked up and grabbed.
You can do that?
Just walk up there and grab it.
He just walked up.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's do this again.
Oh my god.
I thought I had more time.
I legitimately thought I had more time.
I didn't think he would just walk up.
I was a fucking fool.
I actually was a fool.
He just fucking walks up.
I had to defend it for another minute.
It's fine.
Okay.
What's he gonna do?
Flank me.
Here we go.
We figured it out.
We figured it out, guys.
There's no way.
There's no way he's gonna do that again.
There's no way he's just gonna walk up again.
Wait, am I the only one alive?
Guys, I'm the only one alive!
I'm being tracked.
I'm not.
Guys, I'm not the only one alive.
I'm being tracked.
What is he gonna do?
Get over there in one second?
Oh wait, he is.
Wait a minute, he is.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
That's fucking right.
I'm better!
I'm so much better than you!
Wait, I lost?
I fucking won, but I lost.
Oh, it's cause they have two.
That's not fair!
I had one!
I had one.
Bro, I did the most damage on these fuckers.
Oh my god.
She won the battle, but lost.
Cause they had two!
Not a clean sweep.
You know what?
That's like...
That's like a moral victory.
They couldn't get a clean sweep.
They couldn't get a clean sweep in the end.
So that's fine.
That's fine.
It's okay.
I was third.
That's fine.
I'll take them.
It was the moment they killed the gorilla.
Alright, let's team up with the dev.
We're ready to play with the dev.
Right now.
I won the mental warfare.
And that's all that matters.
By the way, guys.
You can literally play the game right now.
If you click the link on the description.
That's in the description.
Pinned in the chat box.
So, yeah.
Join out.
Help the stream.
Help the sponsor.
Feel free to wishlist the game.
And also, play the game right now.
You might get into my queues.
I won the mental warfare, guys.
I slapped him.
I'm pretty sure I killed majority of the lobby during that one run where I just started spitting on them.
I just started spitting on them up in high ground.
That's right.
And they deserve it.
I knew that you can buy a memory back.
I just refused to because he was a waste of my money.
I just refused to.
He was the one that died so fast.
So, what's the point?
What was the point when he died so fast?
I'm gonna join the VC.
Let's see.
Where's the... I need to find the VC again.
I have so many servers.
Which one do I go?
Why is there like three people in the...
There's like...
I'm like looking at the server.
I'm okay.
I just have a seasonal cough.
And it's like...
Start here.
Doki voice chat.
Oh, they went to the sick.
Sick.
I called them out.
And then I saw two of them leaving the voice chat.
I was like...
Why is there like a fucking party over there?
I was like, whoa, there's a party in the Doki voice chat.
I was like, let's fucking go.
And as they left, they left the party.
They knew I was coming.
So they left the party.
I'm gonna join the VC.
And then I'm gonna get the...
Let me get my foogie ready.
Hello.
Oh my god.
I am so definitely looking forward to this.
Let's go.
Hey, remember when you said you blacklisted me?
What happened?
I'm back.
And this time you paid me.
So you think you can come into my office?
You think you can come into my home and be toxic and bully me?
Dude, we paid so that I could bully you.
Okay, I'm gonna leave right now.
I can solo queue right now.
I saw you solo queue.
Yeah, and I almost won.
I've never seen the gore lizard be played so badly.
What do you mean?
I got like 7 kills.
You got like 7 kills playing the gore lizard the worst way possible.
Yeah, and that's a talent.
That means if I could play him optimally, I could get even more than 7 kills.
The fact that I...
Who the fuck cares about him?
He told you to get the monkey.
Yeah, but no.
He told me to get the monkey, but then he didn't give me any other instructions.
So he's a bad teammate.
That's fair.
And that's why you're here with me.
So that way I could be the better teammate.
Yeah, so your job is to do the objectives.
And then I'll kill everybody else.
I literally had no other expectation but that.
Yeah, so just like last time.
You're just gonna be a good little objective guy.
And then I'll just be here killing everybody.
Oh yeah, and then you have to make me a gun too.
I have a surprise for you.
You have a gun for me?
How do I play with you?
I don't remember.
Press P. I'm watching your stream right now.
I don't think you added me as a friend yet.
No, I didn't.
Oh, by the way, that's my friend code, guys.
Please don't add me, guys.
Go to find player.
Maybe I should just do it.
Yeah, you should just do it.
My code is right there.
You know what, guys?
No, add me.
So I know you downloaded the game.
Add me right now.
I wanna see how many of you actually downloaded the game.
This is a sponsored stream, chat.
Alright, that's in there.
Guys, I'm fucking you.
You guys are liars.
I have zero friend requests.
You have such fake friends.
Wait, where's the request?
I'm typing it.
Oh, wait.
No, that's not you.
Look at that.
That's a real Dragoon right there, guys.
That's a Duck Automata.
Yeah, the first person that actually added me.
Alright, I sent you a friend request.
I got you.
No, that's not me.
No, I got you.
I know that's not you.
You're the Jedi.
Oh, okay.
I was like, what the hell?
Duck has been the only true Dragoon that added me.
Why aren't you downloading the game and adding me on friends right now?
Your boss won't know.
Download the game right now.
It's only 20 gig.
Use the work Wi-Fi and download the game right now.
Alright, I'm ready.
How long have you had your little seasonal sickness?
What's been going on with that?
Oh, I've been sick for like a week now.
But I'm not sick anymore.
I'm just coughing.
Oh, that's frustrating.
Alright, we better win.
Clutch your kick.
Why did it...
There we go.
Alright, so I'm gonna praise you here.
I'm really proud of you.
You did really good.
Of course!
These people don't know how to aim.
I had such low expectations you would remember how to play the game.
I remembered!
I was farming!
Yeah, yeah, good job.
I played him over.
The other teammate, he's farming way too much.
I don't know what that means.
Yeah, he spent his entire life farming.
He's playing League of Legends right now.
Just killing minions the whole time.
Yeah, that's why.
He's been locked up in deadlock jail.
And that's all he's been doing.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Alright, I have everything muted here.
Alright, I'm ready.
We're gonna do exactly the same thing.
Alright, we're gonna farm.
But we're not gonna farm for like half the match.
Alright, nice.
Wait, when does the gorilla actually unlock?
So, the gorilla takes I wanna say about 5 minutes.
Maybe almost 5 to 10 minutes to unlock.
I forgot what the actual number was.
But he's on this match.
I don't remember everything!
There's so much into this!
Like, isn't the gorilla the best part about this?
Why don't you remember the best part?
I mean, I hard disagree.
I think the best part about this game is killing the snakes.
Oh my god.
Now I know you're not the best player in your team.
You don't know anything.
You have no idea what we're talking about right now.
Oh, you have in-game voice chat, by the way.
Oh, I'm in.
Okay, fine.
I'll fix that.
I was also harassing other people in my game, too.
Oh, see, chat?
He's a fucking bully, too!
I'm just better at it than him.
Oh, no, no.
You don't even know anything.
Guys, I'm basically saving the other players by bullying the bully.
Alright.
I get bullied all the time.
I'm the community manager here, dude.
I gotta like...
I gotta listen to the people who are like, why is Doki Bird fucking threatening the entirety of the community?
The entirety of the monkey!
Oh, Snell!
I can't find one at all.
I found three.
I thought you were supposed to carry me.
The fuck?
I literally found three Snells.
You got RNGs on your side.
No, I'm just good at the game.
Alright, I got fifty dollars.
Alright, we need to get a decent amount.
Like, I wanna say, like, three hundred together.
So, like, if you could find one fifty, I could find one fifty.
We'll be set.
Well, you're sort of behind right now.
I'm trying to pick it up.
You're sort of behind.
I even gave you, like, so much time.
Oh, look at that.
I'm, like, way more ahead of you right now.
Yeah, cause I've been exploring the map.
Where are you even at?
I've been exploring the map.
I'm doing a little Amazon cruise right now.
You're all the way over there in Narnia.
I'm locked in right now.
Can I say I'm not locked in?
I don't think you're locked in.
Look at that.
Literally, the moment you said that, I got a hundred.
Oh, wait.
I'm poisoned.
Why did it cost you so much of your life and your shields?
Because I got poisoned and my teammate's not here to help me because he's not a team player.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Wait.
Wait, where am I?
Actually, I don't even know.
You're, like...
Oh, shit.
Oh, hey, Blue!
Get over there, snail.
Get your ass over here.
I hear them slimy.
Do we need, like, 40?
150?
Is that the goal?
I think we have enough here.
I have 130.
Let's just go straight to our little base.
Let's go to our house.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Alright, guys.
The dev is here to actually teach us the game.
What you learned from me, don't just delete that.
Playing it the dookie way is not the right way, guys.
Delete the gore lizard part.
No, no.
Keep that in.
That was the best part.
But, like, delete the rest.
The gore lizard was the part where I was, like, the best at.
I didn't know it was so possible to make, like, what people would call the most busted part of our game not the most busted part of the game.
What do you mean?
I killed seven people.
I killed seven people!
I thought we were going back to our base.
We are going to our base.
I already, like, unlocked everything.
Look at that, guys.
See?
That's how you play the game.
Yeah, the dookie way is more fun.
I'm not saying it's, like, the wrong way.
No, you were saying it was the wrong way.
You were literally saying it was the wrong way.
I'm trying to add context.
You were literally trying to say it was the wrong way.
I'm the guest here.
Oh, wait, wait, gun!
You have a gun for me?
I got a gun for you, alright?
Hold on.
Let me grab this real quick.
Let's go to a quiet place.
Wait, why?
You should just give it to me now.
No, this is important.
Wait, why?
What if someone comes up and, like, kills us?
Who's gonna kill us?
You've seen the players in my lobby.
Who the fuck is gonna kill us?
We're going into training.
Why do I need training?
I'm already a master.
Even masters need to train, okay?
No, that's not true.
That's what masters are supposed to be.
Alright, so let's go right up here on top of this hill.
Okay.
Wait, is this a sniper?
It is a sniper, alright?
Alright, so, this sniper, whenever you were telling us, you know, hey, there's drop-off, you know, I don't like drop-off.
This bullet doesn't have drop-off?
We went back to the drawing board and we said, alright, we need to do something that speaks, like, the Oki language.
Oh my god, there's no drop-off!
Before you pick it up, just look at it.
I picked it up!
Oh my god, it's got a dick in it!
Alright, I want you to shoot this all the way over here.
You're gonna see not a single bullet drop.
All the way over there.
All the way over here?
I don't know where it went.
Where's the bullet hole?
It's so fast.
Try it again.
I can't tell.
Is there a bullet hole over there?
Shoot that way.
Maybe we gotta, like, get something a little bit better, like, in range here.
Because that's a 4x scope, like a medium-ranged one.
What the fuck are those green stuff that comes out of my bullet?
It's toxic gas.
It's like toxic spore clusters.
Oh my god!
Okay, so what does the gun actually say?
It just says Dokinator.
Oh!
4x zoom cluster, short range.
Let's go.
No drop-off.
Let's fucking go.
Zero drop-off.
Alright, this is it.
See, guys?
Peer pressure works.
The moment you peer pressure a dev, they'll make a gun just for you.
Exactly.
And then all the other players are gonna complain, but it doesn't matter as long as I'm happy.
We're setting an example for all the gamers around the world that make a jillion billion dollars.
See?
If you wanna have fun, don't have bullet drop-off.
It's a hitscan.
Alright, so, and I saw earlier, you know, chat talking about the Diddy.
Diddy is still available in the game.
I did not get rid of him.
He's still unchained.
He's just, you know, in prison.
He's in prison, but his soul lives on.
Just like the gun.
Alright, so let's actually, let's go play some objective here.
Let's go get some kills.
Someone's got it already.
Don't worry.
I got the dookinity.
If I get shot in my back, it's your fault.
Nah, that's fine.
I kinda hope you do.
That's fucked up.
I'm gonna lose the gun.
I'll just get it back for you.
That's fucked up.
I'm gonna die again.
I'm gonna die so many times, so you have to use your money to res me.
I'll get my credit card out right now.
Wait, where are they?
They're like, pretty far right now.
I think we should go over here to B instead, because there's a big fight happening over at A, so Oh, yeah, yeah, here.
This little vortex right here.
Yeah, it makes you jump higher.
Jump into it, but you can get a nice little super slide if you time it.
Where?
I did it.
Where are people at?
They're all fighting over at A, I think.
Why are we not going to A?
Well, we're gonna get some air on them.
I can see where people are at right now.
There's two teams fighting at A, and there's a couple of teams all around here.
You wanna set a fuckin' air strike tower?
Like a precision air strike on people?
Wait, what?
It's glass, Doki!
Just shoot through the glass!
What?
No, that's property damage.
It's a video game!
That's not what God thinks.
You don't bring God in my Christian Minecraft server.
Wait, where's A?
Alright, alright, A is probably way up at the top.
You see that right up there?
Oh shit, you're right!
Alright, let's do it.
Pull the lever, Kronk.
Pull the lever, Kronk!
Alright, let's do a rocket jump.
Wait, there's a rocket jump?
Hurry up, hurry up, hurry up!
Jump onto it!
Wait, what?
What?
Oh!
Oh, that's what it does.
Oh, wait, that's a robot.
Oh, they secured A.
That's why we went to B, because B was just gonna... we were gonna waste our time on it all day.
We were gonna play Waddle Dee.
I don't wanna do that to ya.
Where are they?
Um, they're probably...
They just captured.
They were way up here.
I just marked.
You have a map button.
Maybe press M.
I think you know it.
Yeah, yeah, I've been looking at it.
Yeah, they're like the top map.
I just wanna shoot people.
They're coming.
These guys... I think we're in a sweat lobby, because my MMR's pretty high.
Wait, what?
You didn't reset your MMR in the dev console?
No.
Why not?
I'm a baby.
You're a baby?
You just said you were the best in the game.
What are you talking about?
I'm the best in the game in my ELO!
Oh, I forgot.
Trash can ELO doesn't exist.
Yeah, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa, I'm getting shot at!
Okay, okay, get ready to... I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Whoa, I fell down.
He broke the glass.
How do I get back up top?
Oh, I'm frightened.
I don't know where the top is.
Oh, where are they?
I'm trying to look for them right now.
He's right up here.
He's looking at me so you can shoot him.
I got him, I got him.
I did it!
I hear people shooting at you somewhere.
I don't know.
I know I heard...
Oh, he's right here.
Oh, just missed that.
He's heading up.
He's so low!
There's a guy on me.
Wait, Alan!
Wait, there's a dragoon lobby!
Oh, no.
This is a shit MMR lobby.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I thought you were better.
I am better, I won.
Yeah, so why are you begging for your life there?
I'm asking where you're at.
Begging for your life like a pussy.
Here's the purple shield.
Oh, nice.
Wait, wait, wait.
Right below.
Oh, I deserve this.
I heard a gunshot below us.
I did, because I'm not a pussy.
Have you used your sniper yet?
I did!
I almost killed one guy!
Almost?
You didn't?
Oh, I'm sorry!
Your gun is fucking weak as shit!
I do like...
It's your gun.
I literally got it off of you.
It literally has your fucking name in it.
What do you mean it's my gun?
I can't believe you made such a...
I can't believe you made a weak-ass gun for me.
I can't believe it.
I do 36...
I did 36 damage per shot.
Like, what the fuck was that?
Alright, hear me out.
I do have a confession.
I actually did make that gun just for you.
And I also made it the worst sniper rifle.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I was like, why is this a...
I still killed somebody, because I'm just that good.
That's fucking right.
I hope you...
Kill him!
I did.
Little baby.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should have res'd you.
I can get P. Diddy back, though.
But we need to get more power.
Oh my god, what do we need?
I fucking knew that gun was dog shit.
I was like...
I was like 30 fucking...
30 damage per shot.
And I hit every single shot.
I was like, that can't be right.
It has like the worst drop-off in a sniper rifle I've ever seen in any video game.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god, you were trying to gas like me.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, I'm not...
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
The moment I hit somebody with that gun, I was like, this gun is dog shit.
You were talking about it earlier, how it's wrong to cyber-bully people on the internet.
Chat, I actually would like to say it's me.
It's absolutely...
Only this guy.
Only Doki, though.
Yeah.
Wait, run him over.
I'm gonna fight him.
Why don't you wanna fight him?
He could've fucking died and never played the game ever again.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Right here.
Right up here.
Wouldn't it be funny if he dies?
Alan!
Yeah, you'd like that.
Oh, I killed somebody.
Alright, nice.
We need to go to B right there.
They keep getting away with it right now.
Wait, I'm gonna slap this guy.
For his money and loot.
Every time you slap him, you get shields back.
Yeah, that's why I wanted to slap him.
Okay.
Wait, how much power do you need for the better sniper?
For P Diddy, I think I needed like...
360?
Could be wrong.
I mean, we could try and fight for B here really quick, actually.
I think that's probably the better move here.
It's really close to us.
Alright, you got this.
Okay.
I got the dokenator in my hand, I believe.
Oh shit, there's somebody here.
I'm hit 79.
Huge, huge.
I actually didn't expect it to be helpful.
Where did he go?
He's inside.
I hear him.
I hear him too.
I think he's falling all the way to the ground.
Outside now?
Oh shit!
He's on me.
He's low.
Oh, he's low, he's low.
Yeah, I've downed him with poison.
I got shot by two right here.
Oh, this is sad.
This is so sad to watch.
This is very sad, yeah.
Bro, this...
Did you win?
Yeah, I won.
That's gonna be so sad if you didn't win that after I got them both low.
No, no, that's fair.
That was quite sad to watch in front of me.
Can you drive?
Do you know how to drive?
Yeah, no.
Depends.
Which one?
Depends on what?
It just depends.
Do you trust me with your life?
And I don't think you do.
I just need you to drive from point A to quite literally point B.
It's a big old fucking yellow...
Why?
Why can't you drive?
I'm far away, that's why I'm asking you to drive!
Oh, I already left.
There's no car anymore.
I already...
You should've said, can you stay at spawn and pick up the car?
Like, you could've just said that.
I didn't realize the intention was that you wanted me to drive.
Get over to B.
But like...
But it's so far.
That's why I said get over, bro!
You didn't tell me to get the car in the first place!
You just asked me a yes and no question!
He told you everywhere!
Oh, there's money here.
You're just like...
You're like, did you drive?
And then I'm like, oh...
But there was no context to that question.
I just assumed you wanted me to do something.
I didn't know you wanted me to do something.
I assumed you knew what you were doing, too!
That's why I said get in the car!
I didn't realize you wanted me to get in the car.
I just thought you wanted to know if I can drive or anything.
And I was like, what an odd question to ask.
Do I head over to B?
Is it still possible?
It's still possible!
I'm gonna drive now!
Alright, I'm heading over.
I see you on the map.
I should be right behind you.
No, you're not.
I'm right behind you.
You're like 500 miles away from me.
Not even 500.
It says 200 meters right now on my screen.
What if I just go up and steal it?
I mean, you can.
No, they didn't let me.
I don't think they let you.
I thought if you were closer, you could've helped me.
But you weren't.
You were so far.
So you did lie.
You could've helped me the first time.
I can't get in the car right now!
You had to mansplain about, oh, you need to tell me what it means.
Yeah!
You have to!
I can't believe it.
You didn't doki-proof this.
You should've doki-proofed it.
How should I doki-proof it?
What are some examples of doki-proofing?
Like saying, can you grab the car at spawn and drive over there?
Instead of saying stuff like, do you drive?
Because in my head, I'm like, in real life?
Like...
I thought you were just wanting to know more about me as a person.
I didn't realize it was all about the game.
Also, there's two guys right here that I'm trying to run over.
Oh, I think...
Are they real?
I can't tell.
I'm getting shot at now.
I got shot at by two people.
This isn't working out.
Alright, we're regrouping.
I think you guys spend your money to fucking bring me back.
This is the worst I've ever gotten.
This is the worst I've ever done in the game.
I'm just saying.
You know what?
No, no, no.
I was being nice earlier, but that guy that was running around not shooting you?
That was the top player of the game.
He got queued into... I'd personally DM him and be like, hey, there's this really horrible streamer coming in right now.
She can't aim for shit.
Can you be careful with her?
What do you mean?
The Kord whatever?
That guy?
Which one?
Raiden.
Raiden?
I killed him.
Yeah, I told him to let you kill him.
No, you didn't.
You're fucking lying.
Where are you?
I'm literally behind you.
I have a car right behind you.
Alright, get out of the car.
We're going inside.
What are we doing?
We're going downstairs.
Why?
Because it's faster that way.
Why are we going downstairs?
Our car doesn't fit there.
We're literally in here.
What do you mean it doesn't fit?
No, it doesn't fit in some of the holes.
See?
Look, you're just bumping into everything.
You're not even a good driver.
I'm a way better driver than you are.
I don't know after seeing that.
I don't know.
Why are we locking Gorillaz in?
Is this P. Diddy?
My P. Diddy is in here, yeah.
I can just pause it.
I have a thousand oil bottles.
Wait, you need oil bottles?
You somehow managed to reach out from prison and Wait, where's the gun?
I need to buy it!
That's what we're down here for.
We're getting power to buy it.
I gave you so much.
How much did you give me?
It's like 400 something now.
Alright, let me see.
I didn't see any money in there.
It doesn't even shake my head.
Bro, it says 120!
Oh, that's on you.
That means you're broke.
Broke.
It says 400 for me.
See, it says 430.
Mine says 140 because I've spent power on other things.
Why were you spending money on other things?
I bought the dokinator for you.
That was a waste of time.
It was totally worth it.
Chat, was it a waste of time?
Guys, after this stream just remember to comment on the stream afterwards.
To die was the worst death I've ever encountered.
Game of the year.
How can I fight that?
Game of all time.
Game of the year.
But also game of the year at the end of the sentence.
How can I even defend myself?
That's why you don't cyberbully, guys.
Or karma's going to get you.
I'm going to find whoever Black Slapow is for game of the year.
I'm literally going to find you.
I'm going to live in your walls for the rest of your life.
Jackpot.
Game of the year for action.
Where's the power, bro?
I don't know.
I got 480 now.
By the time we get the gun, the game's going to be over.
There's no B and C, dude.
The game's going to be over.
We got 10 euros, dude.
Game of the year.
Keep bullying her.
Alright, let's go.
Do you need a glass of water?
No, it's just my life.
You're bullying a sick person.
That's so fucked up.
What if it's like...
What if I had something really bad in my immune system right now and you're like...
You're just beating a fucking dog right now.
That's so fucked up.
You're beating up a fucking tiny ass dog right now by saying all these things.
What if...
What if I was gonna fucking... What if like...
It was Terminal and this was the last video game I'm ever gonna play.
That's the last memory you have of me.
I'm gonna put that on my LinkedIn.
There's gonna be an entire article that says indie game developer bullies VTuber into submission after dying from a critical single shot terminal.
It's over.
I'm gonna pin that on my LinkedIn.
I'm pinning it on my LinkedIn and I'm gonna say...
That was the last job you'll do.
I'm gonna transcript everything and just say I'm sorry.
That's fucking right.
See guys, you can make anybody apologize.
See?
Guys, don't guilt trip or manipulate people.
This is what you don't do, Chad.
This isn't working.
Let's just go find B or C now.
I can't find power to save my life here.
I got like 500 things in there.
I have 500 points.
I don't have your 500 points.
Those are your 500 points.
Wait, so you don't get what I put in?
I do, but I spent it already.
You already spent it?
No, I just put 200 more.
I said I spent it on Dokenator the first time.
Just now.
It should be closer now.
It should be closer.
I put 200 in there.
No!
We don't have C!
I have another 10.
I'm trying to get out of this building right now.
How do I get out of this building?
That's offensive.
I'll take that.
Get this Dokenator dog shit out of my hands.
I have...
Just go towards B at this point.
I put more stuff in there.
That's 630.
Go towards B.
I will meet you there.
I don't know how to get there.
You took me inside this building.
No, I'm upstairs.
You took me inside this building and now I'm fucking stuck here for the rest of my life.
Thank god.
And then like...
I'm outside now.
I figured it out.
Just go to B if you can make it.
Looks like there's other teams there.
We can still fight.
We can actually play a real game here.
I didn't even get to be a gorilla.
We're OSHA certified.
We'll get you Monk next game.
I didn't get to be a gorilla.
We'll get you the Monk next game.
I can't believe it.
Wait, are they getting contested right now?
Yeah, they're being contested.
The exclamation points are positive.
Yeah, you can't complain about the Dokenator when you were the one that purposely made it weak.
They're so right.
It wasn't me because my name isn't Dokenator.
Your name is quite literally Doki's in there.
No, no, no.
My name is Doki Brood.
Okay, I got the Bio Core.
No thanks to you.
I'm fucking defending you right now?
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
I got a kill.
I don't see a kill in your name yet.
Oh yeah, let me fucking do everything, I guess.
Oh, there we go.
Let me do everything.
Player down.
How many shots have you been to?
You don't have a blue shield.
You don't level up shield like that.
Yes, you do.
You have enough power.
I'm getting out of here.
No, I don't.
Hey.
Oh shit, are you dead?
I'm not dead yet, but he's trying to kill me.
He's trying to heal up right here.
He's right behind this tree and a rock.
You ping him?
Yeah, I did ping him.
Pick up the live core if you can.
You'll get full health.
Oh, you're so much better.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
I'm gonna beat him up.
Oh shit, oh shit!
Ah!
Okay, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
That's the most I can play in my life.
That was the most I can play in my life.
No, no, it's fair, it's fair.
Okay, let's wait for you to respawn.
No, I don't have respawn.
Hold on, hold on.
I can buy you back.
You couldn't do it earlier.
Buy someone back.
Yeah, because my life was clearly more worth it.
I know, I agree.
I bet you if I look at my damage after this game, it's more than yours.
Oh, you want to put a bet on it?
You want to put a fucking bet on it, dude?
But now it's too late because I'm dead, so it's not worth it.
If I was alive, I would've.
But now I'm dead.
There it is.
There we go.
Get back in here!
Wait, give me the gun.
I don't have it.
I never bought it.
Oathkeeper's verdict is really good, actually.
Oh, okay.
I did have my vehicle.
Okay, so another team stole it.
Already?
Yeah, another team stole it already.
It got out like 5 seconds ago.
They can keep stealing it.
Wait, did they put that thing in the core thing?
No, they haven't tried to count it down yet.
But it says final countdown.
This is the match time.
Oh, we lost.
So we lost.
If we pick it up, we still get more points.
All I'm saying is that if somebody didn't...
Oh, wait.
I'm going to get off the car.
Good luck.
Oh, these guys are so easy to shoot.
I can't even see them right now.
Are they dead?
I stole it!
I can't tell.
Just one died.
Alright,
so they at least don't capture it, so at least we can get an extra one.
I think we got last place.
We probably... Oh, there's a brower right there.
That's unlucky.
We just noticed that.
There's a what?
A brower.
It's like a big ol' croco boy.
Does he give us more points?
Yeah, he gives us more points.
He also gives us more ammo and power.
Really big guns.
I swear to God, I've been playing against this dad of turds for like four games straight.
He's probably in your server.
Like your fine side.
Oh!
I think you queued into West Coast.
Because whenever you joined, we were like where the hell are you?
You were like all alone.
I did have more damage!
I fucking knew I did more.
You had a chance.
I had more...
Of course I had more damage.
Guys, I just need you guys to know this guy's a dev for this game, so he's been playing this game for a long fucking time.
And this is like my second time playing and I'm already out damaging him.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm already damaging this fucking...
I just challenged you to a 1v1.
1v1?
Bro, we have 12 minutes left.
I wanna fucking be a gorilla.
You wanna be a gorilla?
Alright, fine.
I wanna be a gorilla.
I'm not fucking wasting my time knowing that I'm gonna win.
You wanna be a gorilla?
Okay, let's say it.
Just don't accept it.
Where'd you go?
I'm right here.
I wanna be a gorilla.
I wanna win a game.
Alright, we'll get you a gorilla, alright?
We have to end the stream with a win.
We're not gonna get that dog shit dokey bird gun, okay?
Yeah, dokinator.
No, no, no.
It's not...
I did not license my rights.
It's a bootleg.
It's not mine.
Got the ready up?
Yeah, you got a ready up.
What'd you do?
I'm ready up.
What did you do?
There we go.
I did it.
We're searching.
Yay!
I'm gonna go grab a unsponsored Dr. Pepper from the fridge.
Where is...
Guys, I only have three friend requests.
What the fuck is this, guys?
Guys, prove to me that you downloaded the game by clicking the link on the description
What is... Guys!
It can't be three Dracos that downloaded the game.
It's free!
I'm back.
I have a question.
What's a...
Why did you choose a bird out of all animals?
Because I like birds.
Are you sure it wasn't supposed to be a rat?
I like rats, too.
But Doki Bird sounds cutie.
That's fair game.
I'm just asking.
Where's our match?
Oh shit, now I went to six.
Guys, I swear, guys.
This doesn't go to ten, I swear to god.
I need at least ten Dragoons to friend request me.
So I can tell people that I have friends.
I have plenty of friends.
I'm not gonna accept it, but like...
You could've gotten people to be your minion in the game.
Wait, really?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm sitting in front of you.
You see that little cat girl behind me?
On my jacket?
That's actually another VTuber who's a part of our top dogs.
Every time I get a kill and I get Biocore secure, her name gets up in the clan leader.
It's like creator clan basically.
Oh, and I'm not in it?
Well, you didn't fucking ask.
I shouldn't need to ask.
I should be offered.
You know what?
You're real.
Who's in charge of that?
That's all I'm saying.
We had a...
We had Summit and we had DrDisRespect play the games and they immediately searched their names and were like, who are your names after this fucking game?
Alright.
Alright, we're locking in.
This is gonna be the game.
I've always been locked in.
That's why I out damage.
I'm naturally locked in in whatever game I play.
Alright.
Snails.
I will try to get PDiddy back.
All I'm saying is the moment you put that gun in my hand it's over for everybody.
That's crazy.
It sounds like you really like the gun.
I just like killing people in game.
Get over here, snail.
Get your ass over here.
Look for a really big alligator.
Oh, I saw those before.
Yeah, yeah.
He'll have all the good shit for us.
Oh, I got shields.
I have 70 points.
150, right?
I hear somebody next to me.
Where did you go?
There's actually real people coming this way.
Why are they here?
This is our farm.
They're trespassing.
They're not gonna have good guns.
They literally just spawn.
They're not, but like...
They can still definitely catch us off guard if we're not careful.
They won't.
I'm a gamer.
120.
Are you last hitting a creep?
You're last hitting them.
Wait, do you get points for last hit?
You technically do.
Whenever you get a kill on them, you do get points for the kill.
Yeah, I have 150 now.
I'm not finding any fucking snails.
We're farming together, though.
No, it's because we're farming together.
I should probably...
You're the one that walked to me!
I know, because I said there was somebody next to us!
You could've 1v2'd.
I probably could've.
You're a pussy.
You're a coward.
I would've taken that 1v2.
There's a blue shield, by the way.
But now that you said that, I'm gonna take that blue shield.
I'm gonna throw my blue shield and take that blue shield.
You walked by a loot crate and didn't even loot it, bro.
Oh, and there's another blue shield?
Let's go.
Wait, where's our...
Where's our area to deposit?
It's right over here.
The one in front of me?
Is it this?
Yeah, you could go to this one right here, actually.
I'm heading over.
Wait, so do I just get it so we get the blue shield thing?
Don't buy the one in there.
It's gonna cost more power.
We'll just go to a shop to buy it.
Oh, okay, so go to the yellow shop.
Go to the yellow shop to do it.
We need to go here, though, to scan for the...
You scan it now, and then I don't have to.
Yeah.
Shop time!
Is that you that shot?
Yeah.
I deposit 380.
No, no, no, it's over here.
I see it, I see it.
Over here.
P. Diddy costs 675 power.
Oh, we have 380.
Yeah.
I have 280 now.
What did you spend?
Why?
I got you a blue!
If I die, I don't spawn with it.
I get a shitty white one.
Oh, that's on you.
Just don't die.
I'm trying not to.
That's why I bought a blue shield!
Just don't die.
That's all I'm saying.
I think I'm lost.
Where am I?
You're still underground.
Oh, fuck!
I'm going to kill this bot for shield.
I'm killing a bot.
You'll be fine.
I'm going to push, I'm going to push, I'm going to push.
I'm heading over, I'm heading over.
Hey, at least you get your blue shield.
It's froggy?
At least you get your...
Oh wait, it's two people.
At least you got your blue shield.
No wonder I couldn't hit him.
He was lagging all over the place.
I'm lost.
Yeah, you are.
We're OSHA certified.
Just follow the exit signs.
There's exit signs?
Yeah, yeah.
Look at the walls.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Just follow the exit signs.
Oh, nice.
I got it.
I figured it out.
Every time you cough, I want to cough with you.
There's so many blue armors.
I found money.
Yeah, yeah.
I found 135 along the way.
Okay, so we're getting pretty close to Diddy.
How much do we have left?
Uh, 125.
We have 200.
I want to say...
like a little 200 more left, I think.
Bro, why did they make it so expensive?
Well, I built it, and we recently had some changes to how much specific modules cost.
Literally today.
Yeah, but they should have made it cheap for today.
It got a little bit more expensive.
Just for today, it should be a little cheaper.
No, I totally agree.
They should make it cheaper forever, so that way I don't have to spend that much next time.
I think there's someone near me.
I think I heard gunshots near me.
Uh, probably me.
It was like two miles left.
Interesting.
You used the power and, didn't you?
Nope, I don't know where my shop is.
Uh, there are shops underground, too.
Oh, there's one over here.
If I die with this, it was meant to be.
Alright, I have 515.
You have 60.
Is that enough?
Uh, it would be enough if you were able to buy my gun, but I spent money to buy my shield, remember?
So I just need like 200-ish more.
Almost 200.
200?!
Okay, we now need 675.
No, don't do this to me, I'm just a little guy.
We need like 50 or like 60 power left, okay?
I have a guy on me.
Kill him.
I can't.
Why?
He's like, I only have a shotgun.
He's trying to kill me.
I don't know where he went.
He just stopped.
Probably ran back.
Probably scared of you.
Okay.
What?
Oh, where did he go?
Oh, he went that way, okay.
I didn't see him.
I'm just gonna give up.
I'm just fucking trying to farm.
Alright, the good news is, I can buy it now.
Ah, finally!
Okay, I'm gonna go spawn where you are at.
I have exactly the amount needed for 1,000 oil bottles.
Here we go.
Alright, I'm respawning in 6.
I'm gonna head straight to you and then I'll play the game.
Yeah, then you'll play the game perfect.
Oh shit, hey.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I'm driving over.
You're driving over?
Stay above ground.
Wait, there's some snails here.
Alright, now I'm driving over.
I hear gunshots.
I hear a lot of gunshots.
Alright, keep going.
There, and here's all the ammo for it.
If I die, do I keep this gun?
No, but I can give it back to you.
Buy a shield over here real quick.
Jesus Christ.
Because you definitely need one.
Okay.
Can you buy me this gun right here?
Because I need another gun besides my sniper.
Because I gave you miners now.
Can you switch that out?
You don't want that?
I don't want that one.
I want the one that I just asked for.
Yeah, but if you're a gamer, guns don't matter, right?
Except for this gun.
Because this gun definitely matters.
It's exactly what happens.
Right here, right here.
Oh, okay.
I'm not there yet.
Where are they?
He's right in front of you.
I just got shredded.
Oh my god, okay.
I hit him for 68, but I don't think that matters.
Because I have a sniper, so I don't want to risk it.
Oh no!
No, why are you following
me?
Okay, well now we've got two P-Diddies on the battlefield.
I've got one, you've got one.
Oh, they're fighting.
Good, good, good.
I think they're still below ground.
I'm right next to you.
I'm right below you.
I think they're getting out right now.
Yeah, yeah, they're out.
They're out.
Someone's right behind me.
I killed the guy with the core.
Nice.
You can get the core.
Go, go, go, do your thing.
No, you do your thing.
I told you, you're the objective.
I'll do the thing, I'll do the thing.
Do the thing!
He was AFK because he was trying to stream save.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure he was AFK pulling up my stream being like, where are they?
And then I just shot him in the head.
I...
Probably was.
I fucking knew it.
He was like, where did they go?
I have to go all the way over there.
So you gotta protect me.
I'm trying my best.
Me five.
Hi.
Is he on the ground?
I got him.
He's dead.
GG.
That's fucking right.
Karma for trying to stream snipe.
That's what you get.
Trying to find where I was.
Stream sniping in this day and age?
Unheard of.
Oh, someone's coming towards me right now.
I am...
Oh, they have cars, good luck.
Yeah.
Like, I ain't catching up to that car.
At our base?
Oh, what the fuck?
You're so dead.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking dead, dude.
Jesus, they both just weird.
I guess I'll head up here.
It's Eco!
I'm gonna head over here.
Look at that, deserved.
I'm gonna chill up here.
Deserved.
Wait, where do they have to go?
They have to go to their base.
Where's their base?
Uh, I actually don't know.
Oh, they're getting shot at.
Wait, there's a guy right in front of me.
Just look at him.
Oh, I just fucking hit him to the respawn screen.
Alright, they're getting shot at, so we can go over there.
Let's take this bridge.
Wait, there's guys behind.
I'll get him.
I won't actually, but it's a thought that counts.
Oh, I hit 77.
I shot him.
They're right in front of us now, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, they are.
Oh, nice.
Grab it!
I can't, somebody else has it.
Wait, already?
Yeah, there was another squad.
There we go.
The dude moved all the way to the respawn screen, lol.
Alright, you go get that.
I go heal.
Actually, no, I don't.
Woah, why are you shooting at me?
I have nothing.
Oh, I didn't reload.
I didn't reload, I didn't reload.
I didn't reload either, shit.
I got him.
Yeah, but I did most of the damage.
Oh, I got that guy.
I'm dousing right now, I'm too weak.
I got no shields.
Go do your thing.
I'm doing my thing.
Very ouchy, very demure.
What the fuck are these guns being?
Surge beam?
The fuck is that?
Those are really good actually, those are healing gloves.
Oh, I'm not taking it.
I'm getting sandwiched.
Fuck, dude.
Dude, Jesus Christ.
Oh, from there!
Like right in front of me.
No, I lost both the good guns.
I was like, what is going on?
Alright, I'm on my last life here.
You've got three still.
B is right there, we could go back for it.
I need the gun.
Nice.
Holy shit, how do you have so much ammo for these?
I spawn with it.
Yeah, it's a heavy weapon.
You drive there, I use the car.
Wait, they're like right over here.
They won't expect it when I'm like slowly walking over.
Where are they going?
They're like doing a big circle basically.
Like, where is their base?
Right behind.
Oh my God, this guy can't be real.
I refuse to believe he's a real person.
Oh my God, now he hits everything?
Um, I might be fucked a little bit.
No!
He's low!
I'm fucked around!
I'm fucked around.
I'm fucked around because I was like that guy can't be real.
No!
Oh wait, you're dead.
No, I don't have your gun then!
You can buy me back.
I do respawn with it.
Wait, do I buy you back at the base?
Uh, no.
So whenever you respawn, I'll have a little marker for you to follow.
It'll take you straight to it to respawn me.
Okay.
You should have enough power to buy me back.
I haven't bought stuff so... Yeah, you should be good.
Where is it?
There it is.
Sorry.
I was tabbed out.
There's this little blue square hexagon in the middle of your screen which says 140, 136.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's so far!
It's not that far.
You also run faster with the 3 when you press 3.
Oh, it's just like a knife.
Yeah.
I think it's below actually.
Below?
Yeah.
Yeah, fall all the way down.
Don't go right, go left.
Jesus, I'm being tracked.
Why?
I think you ran into somebody's like sports trap.
It's a cool thing.
It's like, how am I being trapped right now?
Oh, okay, there you go.
Alright, give me your gun.
Where is it?
I didn't spawn with it.
I didn't pick what I didn't spawn with.
Okay.
Hold on, hold on.
Let's go over here.
Okay.
Wait, you don't have to buy it again?
There's no way you can afford it.
There's no way, I knew it.
There's no way.
I'm fucking heavy.
I don't know why... Here, here, here, take this one.
I have another custom.
Nice.
It's Kendrick Lamar.
Okay, not like us.
Alright.
Oh yeah, I hear you.
I am disappointed, chat.
I am disappointed.
I wasted my money on a guy that's been feeding all game.
I'm so disappointed.
I would never bring this man back if he was a random.
If he was not a developer of this game I would never bring...
I would block this guy right away.
I would block him.
Oh wait, exit this way.
We still have a chance though.
Exit this way.
How the fuck do I?
See, you should have an extra life for us.
How do I get out of here?
We got an extra life.
Here?
We're going back the same way we came.
This one is supposed to be confusing.
This is supposed to be a really tight quarter.
Wait, is this a shotgun that you gave me?
Yeah, it's a single shot though.
Shoot a shot and get a feel for it.
Okay.
The reload is not that bad.
Yeah, the reload is supposed to be super duper fast.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How long am I going to be trapped?
I don't fucking know.
You know the map.
Wait, where's Gorilla?
I want to be a Gorilla.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go do your thing.
No, no, no, no.
You go put your thing.
Gorilla should be, I believe, right here.
Oh no, that's a robot.
Don't ignore that ping.
I think Monkey should be right here.
Why isn't it pinging?
Okay, you go do your objective.
I'm heading over to Monkey.
Okay, okay, go get Monkey.
Nobody is getting the Gorilla.
Oh, wait, can you ping that again?
Well...
Okay.
I'm heading over.
I don't know if it's on though.
It should be on.
I'm heading over to the Gorilla.
Is it in the admin offices?
Uh, no.
Am I pinging in the right place here?
Sorry.
I'm trying to play at the same time.
Maybe...
You know.
I'm kind of like walking around.
Oh, Creature Containment, I found it!
No!
Can I kill the person in it?
I did, I killed him.
Somebody was in him.
I killed the guy.
Somebody was in him?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, there was a guy in him.
It doesn't even have a name.
I think, literally, I'm not even kidding.
I think somebody got into the Gorilla Lizard and left the game.
Fucker.
I have an invisible gun.
There's no name on it.
I'm looking at the kill feed and there's no name on it.
I genuinely think someone griefed the hell out of that.
I have an invisible gun.
I don't...
How do I shoot?
What happens when you shoot it?
It shoots, but the gun's invisible.
Just go into your inventory, press tab, and then just click on the gun with your left click and then pick it back up.
That might fix it.
No, it's just an invisible gun.
It might just be the bug, then.
We have an invisible bug right now for specific weapons.
Oh my god.
It's not P. Diddy, though, is it?
No, it's the guy I killed, the random dude I killed.
Oh, not P. Diddy, not like us.
Kendrick Lamar, there we go.
It's just a random...
Oh wait, are we gonna get that...
Oh, we're gonna get C.
I'm gonna go for B, then.
Yeah, yeah, go for B.
We got C, easy.
Literally uncontested.
Yay!
Holy shit!
That's a tank to bring a tank over.
Oh, they got a Deathbringer?
Be careful, it's got lots of point...
like, shooties on it.
Wait, why is he looking...
Go to B!
Why is he looking at me?
Unless he's part of that team, I guess.
Maybe he's part of that team, that makes more sense.
Can't believe it.
I didn't even get to be a gorilla.
That was the only thing I wanted to do.
Yeah, no, I feel really, really bad for you.
Seems like someone quite literally got in there.
I can't believe it.
Somebody would do that in a video game?
We're gonna...
I'm gonna go into our logs for this match and see who it was.
I'm gonna go...
Yeah, that's right.
That's fucking right.
Remember.
Oh my god, they're fighting for it now.
I'm gonna wait.
Yeah, no, they're fighting for B.
I'm waiting.
I'm gonna wait.
I have my invisible gun ready.
Holy shit.
Bro, I can't shoot with this gun.
JK, I can.
I can.
This is a good gun.
It's invisible.
I have no crosshair.
Oh my god.
This is not fair.
I literally have zero crosshair for this gun.
Your chat saw an extra life, by the way.
It's right next to you, actually.
It's a big old plant right here.
There should be a heart in the middle of it.
Oh,
this one.
Yeah.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright, I'm here.
They have a bio core.
I'm going behind them.
This invisible gun, they'll never see it coming because I can't even see this gun.
I got him!
Alright, I'll get the core.
Oh, that was the guy with the core?
Okay.
Hey, that's PDiddy!
Oh, you found PDiddy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I found it!
Obviously, the invisible gun is actually OP.
I just can't see anything on it.
I'm reloading.
Are you okay?
Oh, he's coming over!
Holy shit, he's heading over to me.
Broke him, broke him, broke him, broke him.
Where is he?
Oh, dude, he fucked me up!
I fucked him up, though.
Yeah.
Wait, I should...
Wait, you have the core.
He has a tank.
Oh, pick up the core, though, if you can.
No, but he has a tank, though.
It's fine, it's fine.
Let them take the cap.
Let them fight for it.
I'm just gonna stay up here.
I wanna keep my invisible gun.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I just wanna climb up.
The core's still there, by the way.
Yeah, I think the person in the tank wants to try to bait you to grab it.
Yeah, that's why I'm not fucking grabbing it.
That's why!
That's why I'm fucking not grabbing that shit.
Oh, what the fuck?
There's so many people.
There's another...
Is that the same tank?
No, there should be only one tank.
Yeah, that's the same guy!
68?
He's behind you?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to grab the core right now.
Oh my god, you're crazy.
I don't know where... where did he go?
Oh, they're right here, fuck.
Yeah, yeah, I'm trying to find him for you.
I'm literally above you.
I'm literally behind you.
It's okay, they're fighting, they're fighting!
Just run, just run!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running!
I'm watching!
They're still fighting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they don't know, they don't know.
They're literally just fighting each other.
Let them fight.
What the fuck?
This cat is not real, that's not a real man.
There's no way.
He just took three bullets out.
Is that it?
Did we do it?
I don't see anybody dying.
Did people die?
I knocked...
I downed somebody, but I think maybe he got rezzed?
Question mark?
Yeah, that's what I think too, because I don't see any deaths on the kill feed right now.
I don't see anybody running to you, so...
I'll head over.
Oh shit, someone's coming right now on vehicles.
Oh no.
Oh, I'm very far, I'm so far.
I didn't think they were gonna come over.
Leave me alone!
There's like two squads here!
Wait, what?
They waited for you?
Yeah, they like, they drove their ass to me.
Oh my god!
You'll be fine.
We have another life.
Oh bro!
You have another life, you'll be fine.
The other team is actively protecting me, I'm not even kidding.
Holy shit!
Guys, protect him and I'll come back to the game.
All you stream snipers watching right now...
That'd be so fucking hilarious.
I know you're watching the stream.
Protect him!
And I'll come back.
Whoa!
And then I get shot at?
Oh my god.
You can spawn back at the home base here, by the way.
Just click on the little truck icon at your respawn screen.
The truck respawn?
Bro, he like... where did he come from?
I didn't know!
My invisible gun!
I'm so sad.
I lost the invisible gun.
It was so strong.
What was it firing like?
It was like a...
It was just...
It was like a... I don't know how to explain it.
It just feels like a good gun.
If you were to say...
The rate of fire, was it like an assault rifle?
It was like an SMG.
Okay, yeah.
I figured as much as an SMG.
Yeah, but I could do long range with it.
That's the thing.
It was an SMG, but it worked with long range.
Wait, we win?
Wait, they were stream sniping.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking...
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew they were stream sniping.
Look at that, we did it.
Right now, if you're watching the stream, get out!
If you're watching the stream, leave!
Okay, we won.
We still win.
With the truck, we still win it.
Look at that!
We did it!
We won!
I am sorry.
It's okay, we still won.
I got two events claimed.
What the fuck does that mean?
I'm a control freak.
I mean, understandable, but what does that mean?
So, there's...
The big thing with Ascendant is events.
Remember the air strike that we had?
That's an event.
We have tons of those.
Those are like what make...
They're like map modifiers.
And here we go again.
Top fragger.
And more damage.
Honestly, you had P. Diddy.
You had the power of P. Diddy in your hands.
No, it was my invisible gun.
My invisible gun.
Did all of it.
GGs.
That was fun.
It was fun having you.
I'm glad we were able to come back in and play.
I knew it.
I knew he was being a fucking tsundere right there.
Shut up, dude.
Look at that, guys.
They were glad I was back.
All that shit talk he did.
He's a fucking pussy.
I knew it.
Fuck you, your mom, dude.
GGs.
Thanks for inviting me back again.
Yeah, for sure.
Hopefully, your chat feels inclined to give it a shot.
It's a lot of fun.
Hopefully, next time around, we'll get the Doki clan in the game.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, guys.
All right, guys.
Like I said...
Oh, nice.
I got 17 friends.
I bet you don't have 17 friends.
I have...
Let me double check here.
That's right.
How the fuck do you have so many friends?
I have 27 friends.
Guys, you know what to do.
This is my...
I know exactly what to do.
I just need more friends than this guy.
Guys, this is my ID.
I think I have...
Oh, no, I don't.
Never mind.
This is my ID, guys.
As long as I have 27 friend requests, then I'm happy.
That's all I need to know.
Oh, I'm at 20!
It's getting there.
You've had that account for...
maybe potentially years.
But look at that.
I already have 20 friends.
For years?
To be fair, I've only been working here for a year.
I have 21 friends now, guys.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to talk to my chat.
Give some final words.
A huge shout out to all the devs and I guess Jedi for playing with me and for inviting me back!
Inviting me back to try Ascendant again.
Yeah!
Thanks so much again.
We'll see what happens next time.
Maybe I'll have a better shitter gun.
I'm going to talk to my chat.
I'll see you later!
Have a good day!
Bye!
Feel better!
Thank you!
Huge shout out!
Wait, do I have more friends?
We're almost getting there, guys.
If you guys want to check out Ascendant, feel free to click on...
It's free right now!
It's free to play.
And so you can actually check it out at the moment.
Just click on the link in the description or pinned in the chat box.
It really does help me a lot and the sponsor a lot.
If you give it a try.
Huge shout out for them for bringing me back as a paid sponsor.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching me play Ascendant and getting to know more about the game.
Honestly, my favorite part was actually being the gorilla.
The gorilla was just so fun!
You just walk around spitting on people.
It was so fun!
Just spitting on people.
I was just going...
Winton jump.
Winton spit.
Really, the gorilla was better than the invisible gun.
But yes!
Please check out the game and support the devs.
I'm trying to see if there's anything else I need to say.
Trying to be a professional streamer right now.
There's a lot of stuff you can do in the lobby.
I believe the open beta ends on the 21st of October.
If there's an open beta for the Steam Next Fest which means a lot of games are now open for beta and free to play to check out.
Please wishlist the game to support the devs and everything.
Huge shoutout to PlayFusion for the sponsor and The Ascendant.
Even though they were like we're going to blacklist you, don't get it.
They brought me back and this time I got paid to do this.
Haha.
Peer pressure works again.
Everything always goes well for Doki.
Hey guys, I'm going to head off now.
As always I do have another stream.
I have Silent Hill 2 tonight in about a couple of hours.
I do have an off stream collab.
It's apparently another Mario Party collab but I'm not sure if the participants are confirmed.
I'm not sure guys if it's not the same people.
I'm sorry.
It's supposed to be me, Masayoshi, ChocoBars, IronMouse, and Ellum.
I'm not sure though if it's fully confirmed.
I won't be streaming on Twitch.
I won't be because I do have another stream at 5 at Silent Hill 2.
So that's why I don't want to do too many streams.
But yes, I'll see you guys later everybody.
As always everyone, stay hydrated, pause, check out to get that blood flowing, and if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
The time is literally like now.
It's supposed to be like now.
So I'll see you guys there I guess.
Bye everyone!
Bye!